welcome to this video coverage for
around eight of the sink field camp yes
this tournament German has reached round
eight and it's pretty easy to to tell
how many points the tournament leader
has because karana has them all all
seven points the head are possible and
this tournament basically is reduced to
the question can you continue this this
streak and even beat the world champion
the second time to reach 80 yeah this
was the main game of this round of
course but still it's all three games to
look at and I'm going to start with
aronian against maxima holograph mvl
let's see what happened around yeah
Knight f3 and we get a very rare opening
here on the top level at least d6 pretty
interesting move actually that can lead
to some less explored lines deform and
he went Knight f6 so probably this way
I'm ready to transpose to some more
usual grounds like the Kings Indian
after c4 g6 like like this for example
could be questions posed to the Kings
Indian however Aronian flick Knight to
c3 an interesting move the idea is
simply to play a form why not black does
not have anything great to prevent
before he went night be seven e4 e5 and
we have reached the filly doors defense
by a very unusual move order but
nevertheless it's a normal fill adores
an opening that is sometimes a bit
underestimated maybe it's a fairly solid
choice black definitely does not have
them let's say huge problems in the
opening it's probably somewhat better
for white but nothing terribly special
um yeah aronia now played the most
aggressive line possible against
lead on g4 yeah this looks a bit wacky
if you have not seen it before but it is
definitely player invented by Lexi sheer
off some years ago yeah the most
principled move here and i also think
simply the best move um is to take the
pawn on which um mvl didn't do he played
the g6 after some consideration probably
he didn't really expect to land in this
opening and needed to somehow yeah play
this over the board of course he has
done some knowledge but it's not like he
was super prepared i believe yeah the
capture after this this Bishop c4 I'm
white has some quite substantial
pressure on blacks position the rook
here on g1 is simply preventing Bishop
e7 from happening and Nigerian there in
the position so black must play h6 and
after that why term normally goes with
the capture on if I ball looks like
queen bee three like queen bee three
this is the general development plan and
why it is simply saying okay I have
enough pressure here how do you ever
develop your King side and get your
position sorted it's especially
difficult to play in a practical game in
NL assessor black often seems okay but
it's difficult to play okay but g6 was
played and now g5 night h5 was played
and the bishop age 3 this is a new move
it seems so has not been played before
um it then put some pressure on the
center by may be threatening Bishop
takes the seven at some point and taking
on e5 Bishop e3 is more normal but okay
this is certainly playable black now
took on default yeah this pressure
had some effect and now black went with
age six which is maybe a debatable move
maybe it's it's it's interesting the
idea is that after the capture and this
was was not played that after the
capture here the Queen has got this this
additional possibility so let's say
black place 95 just to show the basic
idea then check black somebody has this
this big check coming so white cannot
easily expel the night with with F 1 F
word for me five they are taking us I
don't like a good idea anyway in this
stage Aronian played very interesting
will be 2 47 looks a bit we had to
somehow let's say develop black with
this but it has a concrete point after
the recapture he went age form therefore
keeping the pawn on d5 for the moment
which makes them yeah black sort of
question himself well what are you doing
with the night on age five yeah this can
never really return and yeah how do you
handle this space lack of space on the
Kings side yeah he went Bishop e7 in
this position which does not seem to be
a be sufficient um very interesting
movie is the move c5 which looks really
ugly at first leaving this gaping hole
on d5 but it has a very concrete very
concrete idea if we look at this we see
that this is not that bad for black at
all he's got Bishop g7 coming Queen e7
at long castle this is the idea and look
here i think has pretty decent chances
in this position it's not it's nothing
particularly dangerous alternatively
like also could consider to to prepare
long castling in other ways like with
them let's say c6 Queenie seven but I
like c5 an interesting
yeah bishop is seven now I think was
clearly insufficient and we see why
white took on h6 now Bishop takes h4 we
should be three yeah and and here black
simply does not have a satisfactory move
to get get long castles prepared you
obviously cannot cancel short anymore
this is far too dangerous with the pawn
age 6 the H file open and he went c6
alternatively this move looks looks very
normal but it's not playable at all
night a three double attack here right
d5 and here and first to think okay
there's some stuff hanging on the white
side as well but group takes h5 with the
idea to play Knight takes f6 winning the
queen is ending the game immediately we
need seven isn't possible at all and he
went c6 to other tool in some other way
prepare long castles but this was
punished with the very powerful move
Knight f5 Jack using this this night on
age five black really does not have a
good reply he captured with the pawn
yeah if you take take with the bishop
alternatively white recaptures and now
simply threatens to take on a g6 here so
let's say queen e seven so yeah white
can capture or player play a queen move
to Castle long let's say here are the
screen III I'm sorry I overlooked that
then Queenie three threads so we need to
do this this first sets a castles and
then we can decide to take others even
Queen G for coming yeah this is a
disaster early night f5 he took with the
pawn and Queen takes h5 Bishop f6 and
long castle see how White's position is
far too powerful black now needs to get
the King out of the middle as soon as
possible and this is what happened
here and now you don't even have the
time to get to play move like we should
be five are you simply don't don't stand
to this type of position I also note
that white has the age pawn which is
super dangerous now a very very bad
position you went with this Bishop takes
Queen e6 yeah here's a one critical
position here you can argue that may be
an erroneous move it's not technically
the best but it still preserves a huge
advantage if I read this correctly he
said afterwards that he had considered
to play move like King be one just let's
say keep the position as it is and
improve from here one big point is that
black can never really take here because
of Queen a fire which is surprisingly
powerful Quincy 7mate and well checkmate
that's not much better so here black
needs to give up the Queen in to avoid
mate next move on go after that King be
one is maybe just from a technical point
of view better but if I've is just wrong
it makes sure that those those bishops
are traded and blacks counter place
completely nipped in the budget cannot
really do anything now after h7 this H
porn is paralyzing black so why it has
an overwhelming position note that he is
not any material down it's just a good
as it is rupee eight and Queen f7 yeah
around here you can look for
improvements for white as it really
looks like blankets on the ropes the
capture is probably still okay but maybe
a step in the wrong direction because
taking the pawn somehow opens up this
possibility that black might get it back
and you could certainly argue that white
has all the time here to to improve so
let's say moves like King B 1 a 3 those
improving moves they are certainly
possible black cannot do much here
really another point after this could be
like King B 1 a 3 to try to do something
with the c3 night which is at the moment
mostly looking at squares that are
controlled by black like like this and
white could try to improve this slowly
um he took however rookie 7 and the real
l 11 problem comes now here here white
had a choice could play him the check on
g8 or return with the Queen and he went
with this check on g8 which in a way you
always want to play it looks looks cool
to put the quittin on this controlled
squared but it seems that Quincy for him
it was still very strong if we check
this black can not take ya to start with
the check the easy stuff picking up the
rook so it keeps the pawn on the board
for the moment enter still get some
ideas in like 95 and so on this this was
a possibility note that after be five
white can take ya s after Queen takes
tackling g8 we have a different
situation rook e8 Queen g7 this is
surprisingly strong for wide yeah there
are ideas like oops just like that if
black plays this there is this move
threatening arookie 6 Quincy for had
some very strong points and still would
have preserved a very big advantage
check after this check however and King
c7 matters are not clear at all the
problem was that aronian has based had
based all this on the next move and it's
not working however I think alternatives
don't convince some as well the move
Queen g8 simply simply didn't didn't
help much he went with rook GE one and
with this move he simply overlooked um a
tactical little detail black now oops
could just take the pawn they are not
reacting to the attack on the Queen at
all yeah other moves don't work I mean
like I could to capture with the adult
but stuff like that of course is very
check it's very clearly good for why'd
ya hear the Queen and porn are
completely paralyzing blacks rooks and
what what we'll do is oops oops and
resins black has no way around that just
just do win so this was not possible and
it's simply that that he had overlooked
something with this move here it's a
it's really funny why it has no way no
way now besides what he played you can
easily lose with moves like that of
course like jakiya and white needs to
take here on age 7 and then black took
here yeah yeah yeah and suddenly we have
equal aterial again and I mean okay we
had equal material also before a couple
of moves ago but the h-bond is simply
gone and here it's simply not much not
much happening this is a completely dead
position it's a bit weird that that for
instance stock free she gives black an
advantage not much like 0.3 but there's
simply nothing going on why does never
going to lose this and we are back check
we had some some more moves but I draw a
greet in this position yeah somewhat
typical game here for Aronian in this
tournament there are he had streaks of
very good play and then some some really
bad mistakes due to bed too bad shape
maybe also bed bed health shape ok let's
look at Nakamura to par off next also a
game of two players that don't have a
very great tournament but to pull off
his amp he had won some games and this
it has a bit a bit at least recovered um
ok let's get ahead we surprisingly got a
balloon defense which maybe could have
been expected in the game kawana Carlson
and there we didn't have a Berlin just
to to to get good news across for those
looking forward to watch the game in
this video and haven't seen it before
yeah the Berlin here Topalov has played
this but never with any any great
success however he went for it in this
game yeah this time the camera is going
going for the endgame check the Berlin
Wall endgame yeah this is one of the
many setups that black hairs it's a
really a maze of lines with with 92 e7
Bishop d7 h6 all kinds of things are
playable we get a fairly normal position
one idea by the way of 97 is exactly
this regrouping getting the night to g6
sort of untangling a bit and maybe
allowing under the right circumstances
to put the bishop on f5 or simply to
play Bishop e7 to get them get a bit
more from harmonious set up on the King
side note that what sometimes can really
be forgotten black has played King da 10
Teag you can never castle age 6 king
edge too by the way if black cod castle
in this position he would he would be
here simply better the problem really is
that from a structural point of view on
man this is maybe the wrong word but
then this somewhat imperfect
coordination of black's pieces due to
the
lack of cancelling rides it's really the
reason why white has anything in the
Berlin if he has anything at all but
when it's something it's based on on
this fact yeah okay we get a pretty
normal position I guess g4 it seems to
be a relatively new idea here this is
this idea quick quick G for coming but
it still seems like a fairly normal
position to me h5 but I must admit that
I am really not an expert on this
opening I mean I have had played it a
number of times actually it's black some
years ago but it's really such a
strategically complex opening that I
really cannot cannot say that that I
know it too well what seems clear that
in this position nakamura went for 92 g5
and it seems that this is not a very
successful move but only due to to palos
very strong reply you could argue that
this looks like the only move anyway and
this was my initial reaction Bishop c8
yeah what else looks like black needs to
do this anyway you don't want white to
take on e6 but the big point of this
move is is far deeper the thing is
probably nitey to g5 was played with the
intention to go e6 can only guess
because otherwise if we see in the game
this does not have any point this
however is not good at all due to bishop
disease check kingi to and now the very
strong move f6 that's a great concept
why does just invited to jump to f7 and
if he does black will take on g4
captures and now Bishop d7 this is just
very strong very strong right now if
white captures now look at this position
black as an exchange down and has a
night on h8 looks very weird but this is
a strong bishop if you ever want to
d 1 this is a super-strong bishop the
pin in connection with the other bishop
make sure that this night is never going
anywhere and black is just an intending
to build up pressure on this night white
cannot be free in this position there is
96 to H for coming Nigerian is winning
here this is not just a compensation or
anything black wins give it to an engine
it's minus 1 point 1 point 2 minus two
big wins but this is not easy at all to
see beforehand for a human player so
very well played here with bishop see
aid ya na camera maybe now recognized
that all this was not working and he
just played a normal move in term yeah
the night on g5 is simply pointless
peace you have to retreat it somewhat
later and it does not make much sense
there the general the thing is that
while black hats the two bishops as he
always does in the Berlin and why does
not have much to show for it at the
moment is structure with knights on f3
and g5 is it's not very not very
promising you want very often you want
to play f4 f5 for example and this is
very hard to achieve you simply have
badly coordinated pieces while black
gets in this break and this means that
he will open up the position even more
captures now we get to this position and
it's very well known if Black gets this
this open town getting rid of from this
King side space disadvantage and it can
open up the position for as bishops then
he normally is it's already better the
bishops are simply simply powerful and
of course it looks like this is too
against one and here black has a double
porn on the queenside but the piece
activity especially after bishops is too
yeah it's too too powerful it's a very
difficult position for for--why to
defend yeah rook h1 this was maybe an
additional an inaccurate move that the
problem is after this maybe nakamura
wanted to give the check in verse but
this is not lead to anything after King
e6 King us perfectly safe there if you
look at this position we check here and
on d3 excellent for black man he just
retreated I'll put it back let's say and
now it continued what the pile of wants
to do use the light squares the light
squares are weakened because the light
squared Bishop is exchanged from from
the get-go and you know I has no active
play at all here it's simply simply
terrible position and the Palo plays a
perfect game Ian really big there's only
one point one little point where he
could have played better other than that
is simply all the best moves yeah g4 now
is also week black has gained upon
almost pianist was very very logical and
development from the from the initial
problems that he had yeah like now can
activate all his pieces two bishops
against two nights check and here's the
the only little inaccurate move that to
parlor place but it's not it's not
substantial he's winning in any case um
b5 was wasn't a little bit more accurate
as it prevents night see for all
together and you can just push the sea
porn after that he he instead captured
here which after not
c4 b5 takes takes takes leads to a
winning rook endgame which is yeah a win
is a win is a win the other thing was a
little bit simpler but I guess when is
good enough just one point to own in a
chess game they continued a bit check
but here we have a situation where
simply a flexed position is too strong
it is the pawn but it's also the
activity black king is invading and
white has no no compensation for that
yeah here if white takes on d6 king f2
is a very well-known hook and game of
course with the f porn promoting and we
have the this is the lucena position i
think it's called in english in germany
call it building a bridge later and i
would definitely do that on the channel
at some point with when i do basic rook
endgames yeah this was played in d5 and
here nakamura resigned the game there is
really no point it was also f3 coming
and white will lose the the f porn in
the long run um yeah very good game but
to follow pretty much without any any
mistake just one little inaccurate move
yeah it seems that like him who I really
am p is is in bad shape yeah but Kenya
what can you say the round the wrong
before he had this pretty terrible loss
against cards may was lost out of the
opening and he had seemed that this idea
that here that he came up with with with
King 2g 395 was simply backfiring and
leading to a pretty unattractive yeah
endgame ln gamma this is sometimes the
middle game called the mini game without
Queen so because that I all other piece
on the board
but it was really a very unpromising
position and he got very nice the out
plate but Apollo okay so let's look at
the main thing of this round kara wanna
against Carlton the seven out of seven
guy against the world champion ok we
have a Sicilian very a very positive
development seeing a good fighting
opening it was in a way to be expected
that cards and does something on the
active site he had to announce that he
wanted to try to win the game which
makes lots of sense of what I mean makes
sense in any case to try to win a game
but considering the development of this
tournament with the wind cards and could
make it down a little bit more a little
bit more bearable let's say yes a
Sicilian but it was hard to predict the
following aha the accelerated dragon yet
not a very common choice at top level
especially in this move order we
sometimes see the accelerated dragon
with this move order for example this
was played in in Carson against the MBL
earlier in the tournament the move
orders seen here is not why not move
order this is the original move all of
the accelerated dragon this isn't seen
very much at a top level due to the line
that kiwanis is playing now the
well-known maroc see bind with c4 taking
space and preventing like to play a d5
basically ever and this is a very solid
line for black as well it's not like
black as in terrible shape here but it's
normally not very attractive to top
layers as you have little room for
activity it was a bit surprising that
went for this Knight f6 93 d 6 yeah this
is one of the principal lines what black
wants to do here is to take on deform
and get the Queen to deform if white
goes here it's a mistaken idea for
coming and why does not coordinated well
you don't want to take on c6 for example
and something like this is downright
downright awful white basically has 92
here interesting move Bishop e2 or f3 +
f3 was played back i wanna very
interesting choice it has some points
and we see some of them in the game
castles and Queen d2 all this is very
normal white setup always involves this
f3 not always but almost all of the
times every move he sets up the center
makes it difficult for black to do
anything like a 65 is basically
impossible yeah here black has a choice
he can try to get active on the
queenside with moves like a six and
later apostle will be five or you can
play what cards are played he went with
a five this idea with a 5 has gotten
popular in recent years but normally in
another problem or let's say a very
similar position we should look at this
because it's important this is a very
comparable line if you look at this it's
the same position but here this is a
bishop only two and not the porn area 3
and here a 5m has turned out to be a
pretty interesting choice for black the
important thing is if white now goes b3
to prevent the the idea of a for gaining
space and black just takes yeah we have
we don't have f3 plate and in the game
this wrinkle has led to the fact that
white can play b 3 so we can avoid black
playing a form what black wants to do
ideally is to get in this a for Queen a
5 yeah get this space on the queenside
and maybe then we should be six rook c8
likes not better here but this is
considered to be a slight achievement
for black if he gets in this push and
now be three has prevented that black
however can still play a foreign cards
and did but now White has before it's
very important that the every point is
always covering before so that night xe4
it's never a possibility it turned out
that when I was looking at the game I
didn't know when I was watching that
this all had been played before and yeah
not with particularly great results to
be honest I think that this is not a
very great position from black he he
went Bishop be six looxcie 197 yeah it's
a one way to try to get some counter
play against the c-4 porn the big
problem is white has a space advantage
and what does some is black doing to
oppose that if white is given lots of
time he will simply m yeah expand slowly
or sometimes not so slowly i'm here with
f3 being played even those aged for
ideas come into consideration let's just
look how it unfolds Bishop e2 Knight b6
and now night b5 was played interesting
choice and a new move it seems they're
there already was a game with 95 which
also looks perfectly normal and let's
say after something like this wyd
certainly is a bit better he's got a
good space advantage c4d five
possibilities to play c5 at some point
maybe even right away it's not not a
stupid move and here white is definitely
at least slightly better with his space
the whole opening choice by Magnus is a
bit puzzling because it looks fairly
unattractive to be honest maybe this f3
move order wasn't in his focus when he
prepared yeah 95 however was also very
interesting what keeps more pieces on
the board the idea is to put the night
on a three if black now would have
played Luke c8 looks very normal then
you can play the night oops to a three
that's not a bad place for the night it
keeps c4 securely protected and yeah the
black configuration on the queenside is
really am not making so much sense if
you consider that in the long run the
night on b6 it always needs protection
by the Queen and white may play a let's
say castle sruthi one Bishop f1 Queen f2
were tickling the night where is it
going the whole situation is really am a
bit a bit problematic from like you
don't have any active idea maybe at five
but this is also notoriously weakening
like the e7 porn and de farm not very
not very good I must admit that i'm a
bit biased because i have played the
white side of this opening so often and
i don't know i have score like eighty
percent or something even against good
players so i'm i'm a bit big bias as I
as high as I same okay a three was
played to prevent night a three and yeah
here ninety-four was played Bishop d7
want to keep this piece and now come on
I really went for the most aggressive
way to go about it he also could have
just cancelled with a I think convenient
advantage he went H form really showing
that he's not in there too to play a
play Tim HS so h4 h5 we want to meet
black okay and while h5 is a pretty
logical reply to prevent
the median age five probably should be
played yeah and now really g4 why not
yeah why does using this big space
advantage to even expand on the on the
kingside black does not have any play
against whites King in the center that
tons of pieces around it and black skin
gets opened up I think this is just very
dangerous black now captured what else
and went 05 I think this is probably
probably necessary to do to get some
sort of play going we see and we see
what play I mean II 5 yeah white now has
a choice where to go with the way the
night he went to be 3 which is probably
strong night b5 was also possible after
which black I ever can take and play d5
this is a maybe not so attractive
looking in comparison note that a move
like Bishop takes b6 here is really
awful takes let's say but this why to
take then all of a sudden black invades
on the dark squares you absolutely never
here can take on b6 and give up your
huge defending Bishop looking at all the
dark squares however h5 would have been
possible still with a good position for
a wild night b5 was also possible but he
wanted to keep this on the board I guess
and also maybe half night 85 coming um
nap Bishop c6 was played Bishop e6 was
also possible but also I guess be better
for why'd ya here after Bishop a three
cars and went f5 and this was the idea
why he put the bishop on c6 you want to
counter play on the on the diagonal and
yeah what a wild positioning out of this
relatively quiet opening they reached
this um this mess yeah come on are now
captured and went to a five
just very strong very strong play now
blackest is really in some trouble what
should he do if he takes on on e4 it is
very simple white will pick up those two
points and with it the game now there is
no no count to play really wide wins
what else is there he could have thought
about this exchange sacrifice but
ultimately this shouldn't be sufficient
and we also have the age porn running
down the board it's an exchange still he
went with with F for a bishop f2 and no
Knight a for this is probably the
toughest defense now captured on c6 beat
eggs and short castles what a move shot
castles yeah this came to a big surprise
I came as a big surprise for for the
spectators and commentators and I also
think that I'm a bit stunned why short
castles was played it looked far more
natural in a way to play him like a
rookie one on let's say h5 kingi too
yeah so nice that basically keeps the
King in the center but he drove in short
castles after move like let's say h5
it's not really dependent on one single
move why this is having a fantastic
position really he's got long term the
two bishops a weakness on d6 blacks king
is exposed and probably you will get get
this attack even yeah even increase that
will be more dangerous um as it as it
it's developing very very difficult for
black after castles it seems that black
get some at least a playable position
again c5 b5 ok so this structure now has
been has been frozen and here it's a
matter of timing what black wants to
achieve is he just wants to he just
needs to keep this structure getting the
night to be 6 let's say and the bishop
on e seven then all this is not so
dangerous he's got a decent defensive
position the problem is however after
Bishop f6 king h1 that here you need to
be precise and now cards made a mistake
it turns out that Knight b6 what he
played was an empress i smooth order it
has one very big drawback he should have
played a rook a7 and this is still
fairly unclear this position check maybe
King a jade and yeah black keeps this
protected and also he has this idea
totally totally a difficult position
that the computer gives white and a
pretty substantial advantage wants to go
rook g2 but this is very murky and could
have gone either way it's good for white
but very difficult to play by the way
black couldn't capture here because of
check and this and now Luke edge 2 will
be deadly Knight b6 yeah 96 and now we
come to the decisive the size of moment
of this game um it looks fairly natural
now for white to attack the d6 pawn rook
t1 but what rook he went rook cd1
and this turns out to be a mistake um
after Luke fd1 however white was
basically winning it it's just like that
d6 Hanks and black must come with that
yeah and now White has a very strong
move Bishop takes e5 the idea is that
after D takes check Queen g2 he win the
Queen and yeah until you're black you're
black is lost there is simply simply no
defense anymore the sea porn is gone and
with it to the whole structure black
must play some some so move like King
edge eight legs and then white simply
drops back and comes with see 5 or still
group g1 those kind of ideas it's just
this important porn was getting lost
Luke fd1 and you can really tell it like
that Luke ft one was the 80 most like
ants no no defense there might be six
was really giving wyd this chance but
karana playgroup cd1 which is in a way a
good sign he's human and now and after
King age eight which simply steps out
check of this after King edge eight now
see for Hanks really and gives black the
the counter-attack that he needs if
white now is not taking on d6 and
playing a slow move I know something
like that then black has the time to
cover his weakness here and then with
Luke g8 continue in the same way that I
had shown before with rugae seven so
white basically needs to take everything
else and doesn't make any sense so it
was traded at night c4 yeah and after
luke t 593 black really had just about
enough plane to keep the raw yeah we now
get opposite colored bishops
we should be too yeah vitam here
definitely does not have any any
substantial chances after rook takes for
example black girl captures on h4 and
here the e porn is also a source of
counterplay yeah i note that let's say
if why this is going for a move like
that you can still lose it's really the
typical thing with the opposite colored
bishops there should be two was played
to prevent any of those ideas and now
black took here and traded rooks yeah
that's the simplest way check yeah this
is where you want to be the bishop on b6
it's active it protects the e3 porn
which is always the counter play the
counter play sauce and wide really has
no way forward to the king is blocking
this the bishop is blocking this nothing
nothing to do here the game was some
agreed wrong so at the end come on i
didn't manage with the 80 which would
have been I mean okay Pierre even 70 and
said beyond any words but it really was
possible he had this let's say let's
call it a match point here when when he
went rogue cd1 rook ft one would have
probably seared the deal to to get the
the second win against Carlton yeah he
clearly is struggling with his openings
I mean what what else can you say he had
trouble in some games which is not new
in a way but you know but also you you
would have thought that well he should
some time I what time should should
improve his openings but again he got
into trouble I mean this this position
here is really unattractive and in a way
should have been part of the preparation
if you prepare the accelerated dragon
you
should prepare the more oxy and it's not
not clear I mean this cannot be a
position that they really wanted to have
so this is a bit bit mysterious okay but
a very interesting fighting game in
which you even maybe could have looked
at in more detail but i'm a bit limited
in time today i must admit okay i hope
you enjoyed the coverage here for the
eighth round we have two more rounds to
go I mean of course the tournament is a
seat for caruana now is this three
points ahead with two rounds to go so on
it's it's about rating points prestige
but still I expect interesting chest we
had very interesting games although in
the whole tournament it's a very very
little uneventful draw sort of boring
games ok I hope you enjoyed it I'll be
back tomorrow thanks for watching